first of all congrats on the series i
i thought uh everything about it was so
well done
um i just want to start with that but um
something interesting about you that i
when i was you know uh getting ready to
talk to you is that you went to the yale
school of drama
i did i did um i i would have met i mean
hardly it's not like everyone's gonna be
able to go to the school i'm curious
maybe if you could share what that
experience was like and maybe
some of the lessons you learned that you
still take with you
when say getting ready for a role like
this
it's hard it's um a lot
of eyes on you at one time
and um you know helping you
sort of sift through all parts of
yourself you're forced to be very close
uh to yourself and get to know yourself
very well
and show it very closely to your 15
other counterparts
i think that's um the biggest part of
the training right is watching these
15 other amazing people uh do what they
do and so you just
want to rise to the occasion um it's
just taught me
how to get into the meat of who a person
is
how to think like a human i think is the
biggest takeaway
from school how to think like a person
because that
that's what you are of course i've been
asking everyone
the same next two questions who i've
been talking to in the last few months
uh what tv series would you love to
guest star on
insecure i love insecure
uh and what movie have you seen the most
send it off
okay i appreciate the honesty um uh
one of the things that i really
responded to with this series more than
anything is i love the fact that
none of the characters in anya's
character in her orbit
are quote unquote villains they're all
there's no
person trying out to get her you know
trying to get her or take away
something um can you sort of talk about
that that it
the series doesn't really have a villain
no
and i love that that it doesn't because
i think she's her own
worst enemy she's the person
um that she's fighting against every day
when she wakes up in the morning
and i think everyone else is there to
sort of help her sift
through the muck of um
the the of who she's who she's trying to
be
um when she can very much just be
herself and live in that genius
completely um the series does a great
job at
talking about what is family the cost of
genius
um there's a lot to unpack what was it
that
for you what did you respond most to
with the story and the material
definitely the language first in terms
of like
what connected me to it to begin with it
just didn't require any like
muscling or pushing it just fit very
lovely very close to the skin
very real um and like on a deeper level
i think i most identify with uh
beth's imposter syndrome and feeling
like she doesn't really
you know belong or maybe she's not
really as good as she thinks she is or
people say she is it's like
you know a common theme through it and i
think many people will identify with
that
i'm a big fan of scott frank i would
imagine you are as well afterwards
uh can you share a little bit about
working with him and maybe what
surprised you about his directing onset
scott frank is the most generous
kind patient i was so shocked
um this being my first job to have a
director ask me what i thought so like
the first time
we were on set he was like i don't know
about like what do you think
i'm like you know what i think and i and
i love that he was willing
you know to listen to my thoughts and
make space for me
um to continue to grow as an artist and
in the space he
very very like no ego just wonderful
another thing about the series obviously
the cinematography the production design
the costumes
there's like no weak link in the chain
um
how does that affect you as an actor
when you're stepping on set
and they've done such an amazing job at
bringing everything to life
it's the power of the ensemble
these things don't happen without the
100 people
working behind the scenes everyone is
working their hardest
so i think it can go one of two ways you
can crumble under the fact that people
are waiting for you to do your best work
or you can rise to the occasion of
everyone working around you and
you know you rise to the occasion when
it's great you know
steel sharpened steel and everyone
collaborated well
together uh i'm curious this was your
first time doing a series like this
you know first and uh so you steven's
your dp
um are you paying attention to the lens
that he's putting on
or are you just so in the moment of like
i need to get my performance right
are you sort of pushing away what's
going on with the camera
uh no i'm listening i'm definitely
listening
i'm trying to absorb as much as i can
like many times i would prefer to sit in
and instead of have my devil
come in just so i could learn what was
happening the conversations that were
being had and what was
you know what was trying to be achieved
um
i definitely uh was a big listener
trying to take away as much as i could
that's something else i wanted to know
um
what did you because this is obviously a
learning process for you as well
you know working with such gifted uh
people
um what did you take away from the
experience that you want to apply
to you know future things or what did
you learn that you could sort of share
everything uh just sort of how to go
from
the classroom to practical learning and
how to track with the camera how to feel
a camera behind me
if i can't see where it is which is one
of the more difficult lessons
um how to make sure i'm hitting my mark
i think it's just a very
delicate dance between the technical and
the hard work and you really gotta
make it go together i'm obviously very
excited to see joel cohen's macbeth
um what what can you tease about what it
was like working
uh with him on that project
another wonderful learning experience
another amazing director being patient
caring what i think
i have been so lucky at this early point
in my career working with such generous
people
um i i really just hope to continue on
that path
it was wonderful well one i read that
the entire production was just shot on
sound stages
to sort of give it a feel um what what
can you tease about well obviously who
you play and what it was like
filming on set in these sound stages
um i play lady mcduff wife of
lord macduff played by corey hawkins and
it it just the illusion of it all
is masterful to be on these gigantic
stages with beautiful
images that read so well on screen i'm
not sure i can say too much about
what it looks like but i can tell you it
is stunning
yeah that's funny i have i expect
nothing less from uh
from uh from the cohen's and from joel
yeah you know um hey listen i got to
stop there and i'm just going to say i
really mean it congrats
uh uh you know queen's gambit is
fantastic thank you so much
so much a pleasure